bienvenue au club de l'aube humankind le
berceau de l'humanité
on est à 50 km de johannesbourg en
afrique du sud donc le poteau qu'eugène
vous montrer c'est marque l'emplacement
de l'endroit où le premier crâne
d'australopithèques adulte a été
découvert
donc ici on est vraiment dans le coin
parfait pour parler chaînon manquant
et justement et bien parlons-en de
chaînon manquant dans ma grande série de
vidéos que j'ai fait sur les chaînons
manquants donc l'un des reproches qu'on
m'a fait dans ma dernière vidéo sur les
chaînons manquants celle sur dire trop
de natus je vous mets un petit lien dans
la description et bien on m'a dit
j'utilise une définition qui est un
petit peu un petit peu personnel de ski
h et non encore mais justement si on en
discute avec avec les créationnistes de
ce qu'est un chaînon manquant
on se rend compte que la question du
chaînon manquant est de trouver un
chaînon manquant et d'identifier un
chaînon manquant
c'est juste une affaire en fait de
définition c'est à dire que bat pour
savoir de quoi on parle il faut qu'on
travaille tous avec la même définition
alors justement tâchons de définir ce
que ce serait qu'à chaînon manquant un
chaînon manquant
si vous discutez avec un créationniste
il va vous dire ah ouais bah chaînon
manquant ses c'est un truc parfaitement
intermédiaire entre un humain et un
chimpanzé
enfin il utilisera même pas le manche à
penser il utilisera le mot singes donc
un truc parfaitement intermédiaire entre
un humain et un singe et là on a envie
de dire bah d'accord alors qu'est ce
qu'il faut qu'est ce qu'il faut là si tu
veux j'ai je peux te montrer
australopithecus africanus mi6 place
justement le premier adulte qui a été
trouvée ici à starke fountain c'est un
crâne de singe sur un corps bipèdes
ouais mais non mais non à bombe alors ce
que tu veux c'est un crâne du main avec
un corps de sage et dans ce cas là on a
au monal et 10 au monal et 10 et 20
représentants du genre homo mais il a
des adaptations à
un mode de vie arboricole donc il a
encore des il a encore les doigts arqués
typiquement il a les phalanges qui son
arc et qui est une adaptation à un mode
de vie
suspendus dans les arbres donc c'est aux
mots avec des adaptations à l'armory
colis au monal ai dis donc qu'est ce que
ça c'est un chaînon manquant
ben il va certainement vous répondre que
non que vous n'y connaissez rien que
vous essayez de l'embrouillé évidemment
évidemment que vous essayez de
l'embrouillé parce qu'il ne sait pas de
quoi il parle quand il parle de chaînon
manquant lui ce qu'il veut finalement
c'est pas les chaînons manquants que
nous on n'a pas ce que des chaînons
manquants on en a plein je veux dire la
série les hominidés on en a des milliers
de fossiles maintenant on en a des
milliers documentant depuis sahel entre
opus tchadienne sise donc depuis toumaï
jusqu'à homo sapiens lui ce qu'il veut
c'est un truc parfaitement intermédiaire
entre un singe et un humain c'est à dire
que dans cette danse est magnifique
collection de choses qu'on pourrait lui
offrir comme étant des chaînons
manquants il veut la seule chose qu'on
ne peut pas lui donner et c'est ça le
truc si vous voulez si le sage est un
carré noir et si le l'humain est un
carré blanc lui ce qu'il veut c'est un
carré gris il veut un carré gris le
créationnistes comme chaînon manquant
et ça ça n'existe pas nous on sait que
les chaînons manquants c'est pas des
gars d'écart et gries et des damiers
c'est des espèces qui étaient adaptés à
leur environnement et qui porte qui
avait à la fois des caractères dérivés
donc des caractères humains des carrés
blancs et des caractères de sage
c'est à dire des carrés noirs mais il
avait aussi des carrés rouges des carrés
verts et des carrés bleus pourquoi parce
qu'il fallait qu'il soit adapté à un
environnement particulier donc 6h et
nommant kan devait être découvert par un
évolutionniste ce serait pas un carré
gris ce serait un damier un damier avec
du noir un damier avec du blanc et un
damier avec peut-être des cases grise
mais surtout des cases rouges des
casques bleus des classes vertes dégage
de toutes les couleurs parce que les le
carré gris finalement ne serait adapté à
rien il serait à moitié un truc à moitié
un autre sans être finalement
définitivement rien du tout
donc voilà si vous voulez découvrir un
chaînon manquant qui plaît aux
créationnistes
il faut découvrir ce carré gris dont on
sait qu'il n'existe pas et pourquoi et
pourquoi c'est important que je vous dis
cela c'est parce qu'en fait le chaînon
manquant que les créationnistes veulent
c'est quelque chose que la théorie de
l'évolution ne prévoit pas donc ultime
manche j'ai même envie de dire que
découvrir un tel chaînon manquant celui
qui les créationnistes veulent nous
faire découvrir et bas ce serait
découvrir finalement une preuve que
l'évolution ne marche pas puisque on
découvrirait quelque chose que
l'évolution la théorie de l'évolution ne
prévoit pas ce serait finalement une
preuve contre l'évolution de trouver un
chaînon manquant
donc voilà vous pouvez partager la vidéo
à vos amis créationnistes en leur disant
que bas s'ils veulent démontrer que la
théorie de l'évolution est fausse bas
qu'ils le trouvent eux-mêmes leur
chaînon manquant
parce que ce chaînon manquant nous nous
ne prévoyons pas de le trouver et que si
on le trouve pas ça veut tout simplement
dire qu'on a tout faux voilà je vous
remercie beaucoup d'avoir suivi cette
petite vidéo et je vous dis à très
bientôt sur notre chaîne